the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon update video well my
friends it looks like the day has
finally arrived hbo has released their
first official teaser trailer and i just
have to say it looks absolutely amazing
it without a doubt exceeded all of my
expectations
we are now only a handful of months away
from seeing westeros get set ablaze by
house targaryen and their dragons
now for those of you who don't know
house of the dragon will be set roughly
170 years before the main events in game
of thrones during the era known as the
dance of the dragons this was when house
targaryen started a civil war with their
own family over the iron throne and the
line of succession after king viserys
targaryen died the rest of these
characters will draw a line in the sand
and fight for their side they believe
deserves the iron throne the most
for those of you who don't know king
viserys targaryen had named his daughter
rhaenyra targaryen as his heir for the
iron throne he wanted her to have it
after he was gone but his new wife
alison hightower did not want that to
happen
so she made sure their son aegon
targaryen the second of his name set on
the iron throne instead when that
happens many of these characters will
fight for alison and her son while the
rest will fight for rhaenyra now for
those of you who might be new here i
have already made some videos where i go
over all of the information regarding
these events i will link one of those
more detailed videos down below
now let's go through some of these new
images from this teaser trailer because
they look amazing it begins with us
seeing rhaenyra targaryen on dragonstone
this is where she is living when her
father king viserys targaryen dies
this is also where she will be fighting
from for most of the dance of the
dragons well that is until she takes the
iron throne for herself if even only for
a short amount of time
next we see daemon targaryen walking on
dragonstone with a dragon egg in his
hand right behind him is his mistress
massaria who also becomes the sort of
unofficial mistress of whispers for
rhaenyra targaryen
they're being followed by what looks
like several of the gold cloaks also
known as the city watch of king's
landing now for those of you who don't
know daemon targaryen was actually the
commander of the gold cloaks for roughly
a year he is actually the one who gave
them their golden cloaks which as we all
know is what they later became known for
now another interesting detail you might
not know is when daemon targaryen gets
massario pregnant with his child he
actually gave her his own dragon egg
however king viserys not only demanded
that he get the dragon egg back but he
also said that he should send masaria
away now in this scene it looks like
daemon is having a bit of a standoff
with who i believe is serato hightower
as well as several members of the
kingsguard and grand maester or wild
now for those of you that don't know
daemon and serrato hightower absolutely
hated each other in fact cerrado was
even one of the men who suggested that
king viserys name his daughter rhaenara
as his heir out of fear of daemon
getting the iron throne after he died
however this is just one of the many
reasons they did not like each other
then we see one of the dragons and their
rider flying over king's landing and i
must say this looks gorgeous in fact all
of these scenes look incredible the
cinematography is definitely on another
level in this new show you can see that
hbo spared no expense
now inside of the red keep in the great
hall we see king viserys targaryen as
well as hundreds of other lords and
ladies in attendance his daughter
rhaenyra targaryen is standing directly
in front of him below the iron throne i
believe this is when all of the great
lords of westeros will swear fealty to
rhaenyra targaryen because as i said her
father king viserys did name her as the
heir for the iron throne he was setting
her up to take over after he was gone
this will be when most of the lords
acknowledge this however their fealty
will sway once the iron throne is up for
grabs some of these men who once stood
behind her will no longer do so after
viserys dies and his wife alisen sets
their son on the iron throne before
rhaenyra even finds out that her father
is dead
we then see daemon targaryen and some of
his city watch storm what looks like the
streets of king's landing afterwards we
hear princess rhaenys targaryen say men
would rather set the realm on fire
before seeing a woman sit on the iron
throne
now that phrase alone also references
something that happened to rhaenys that
also relates to what will happen to
rhaenyra
now for those of you that don't know
princess rhaenys targaryen is known as
the queen who never was and that is
because she was once in line for the
iron throne herself but she was also set
aside like rhaenara she knows exactly
what rhaenyra is going through once she
gets set aside for her own brother aegon
in fact it looks like we might even see
the great council at harrenhal the
images are very dark but it does look
like harrenhal when balon died in 101 ac
king jiharis targaryen called the first
grey council at harrenhal to decide the
matter of succession
there were 14 different claims that were
considered including the claims of
rhaenys and her children now rainey's
uncle lord borman baratheon was
outspoken in supporting the claims of
rhaenys and her son lenore during the
great council and lord ellard stark gave
his support to rhaenys and corliss as
well however the claims of rhaenys and
her daughter were rejected on account of
their sex
afterwards rhaenys and her husband
corless valerion used their wealth and
their influence to persuade the lords to
then vote for their son lenore however
lenore was eventually set aside in favor
of balon's son viserys targaryen now for
having been set aside in the line of
succession the jester mushroom would
name her the queen who never was we then
see another large gathering with king
viserys his new wife alicent as well as
viserys's daughter rhaenyra and lord
corliss and rainey's son leonor velaryon
i believe this might be their wedding
given what they are wearing during this
occasion
we also see glimpses of what i believe
is a funeral on driftmark the home and
seat of house velaryon this is something
i discussed in a video long ago when
some of these photos first leaked online
you can see their house banners flapping
in the wind right here and you also see
them drop the sarcophagus into the ocean
this should be the funeral of daemon's
wife and daughter of lord corliss
velaryon lady lena velaryon i actually
think this might happen in one of the
very first episodes now remember if you
want to learn more about all these
characters and their relationships i
would highly recommend watching my other
video that is linked down below in that
video i explain all of these events in
greater detail unfortunately i only have
a very small window to record this video
today so i have to get through some of
these scenes a lot faster than i would
like don't worry though there will be
many more videos soon i'm only
scratching the surface right now anyways
in one of the final scenes from this
teaser trailer we see allison running
right at rhaenyra targaryen with the
valyrian steel dagger in hand this is
the same one we saw arya use when she
defeated the night king
now this should be right after allison's
son aemon targaryen loses his eye
this happened during a fight with one of
rhaenyra's sons luceries as you can
imagine allison gets very upset
demanding justice or an eye for an eye
let's say this will be just the
beginning of alison wanting rhaenara and
her son's dead now at the very end of
this new teaser trailer we get our money
shot when daemon targaryen goes and
visits his dragon as it unleashes its
scorching hot flame right in front of
him once again it looks amazing
if you don't know house of the dragon
will feature roughly 17 different
dragons during the course of its run
over a dozen more than we ever saw in
game of thrones not only that but we
will see these dragons fight and kill
each other and damn near every season of
this show now like i said at the
beginning of this video this new teaser
trailer absolutely blew me away it
greatly exceeded all of my expectations
everything looks and sounds so much
better than i could have imagined dare i
even say it looks even better than game
of thrones did now that's not to say the
story will be better than game of
thrones because i don't think it will
however i think it does look way better
than game of thrones very first season
as you all know hbo now has its black
belt in creating fantasy shows and that
is on full display in house of the
dragon now i know there are still a lot
of fans who are upset with how game of
thrones ended as i am but i don't see
how you can watch this new video and
still think house of the dragon will
suck
i think it's your loss if you don't at
least check out this show i know i
cannot wait for it to get released and
i'm assuming most of you watching this
video feel the exact same way now like i
said a minute ago i will be releasing a
lot more videos about this soon make
sure you subscribe now so you can see
them all right away
as always i want to thank everyone for
stopping by and watching this video i
hope all of you have a great day i will
see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you